Film Courage: What makes a movie marketable?
Alok Mishra, Producer: there could be a
lot of things that make it marketable.
I find look everyone says “Stars sell films,”
it's not untrue. It definitely helps to have
recognizable faces beloved faces that are in your
movie sometimes you can't afford people because
you're low budget sag ultra low budget film so
genre I think that's something that helps sell a
film you have for horror movies there are I don't
know 220 horror conventions a year there's not 220
romantic comedy conventions right so this audience
is a very loyal audience right they they're
seeking this kind of material out they definitely
love physical media so you can sell different have
different revenue streams based off of whatever
kind of movie you've made it's a genre movie
they they're loyal they're very loyal and for some
of them they really don't care what the quality of
the film is necessarily if it took this gross out
slash or something rather and it's the worst movie
ever somebody loves that movie by the way there's
some horror fan that just beloved is that movie's
beloved to them so it doesn't have to necessarily
be the highest quality necessarily but everything
else there's people that are Discerning within
the genre too the people who want some of smarter
films or they're they enjoy the A24 type of movies
which are very in their own rights their own kind
of brand but very interesting and thoughtful a lot
of times a lot of different things can go into it
you could have a movie with no stars but it's just
the most spectacular ballet of violence and action
and everything else that people you don't need to
have any stars in The Raid the raid part two was
even better than the raid part one and you don't
know any of those people at least you didn't at
the time right and they became action stars of
sorts but it can it can be just the way that's
presented it can be so stylistic that it's just
so interesting there's a Russian Film called why
don't you just die which is one of the best films
this guy is the air to Tarantino we met at the
film festival he's a physicist he's a physicist
but he's made this amazing ballet of violence and
and just just amazing the camera work everything
else is just amazing and that Russian Film that's
just a tour de force of violence can be marketable
just because it's so stylistic and interesting
looking right just cut a nice trailer for that
that's very marketable it can come from different
places right people want to see new stuff that
they haven't seen before Terrifier 2 going back
to that it's so Ultra violent that people are
losing their minds over because they haven't seen
something just violent in a lot of a long time it
is just beyond sorry I'm making a commercial for
Terrifier 2 but it's but I'm saying it's different
it's so different it's so interesting that that's
someone's don't marketing campaign hadn't seen
this before you haven't seen this in a long time.
Film Courage: What makes 1BR Movie marketable?
Alok: I think there's a lot of accessibility to
it I think that who hasn't moved to a new city
and felt very lonely even though Los Angeles is a
sprawling Metropolitan City it's very easy to feel
very lonely here you get in your you go to work
you get in your car you're by yourself in your
car driving home you get home you're just kind of
by yourself it's not it's New York where you're on
the subway and you just happen to meet people when
you go out you have to drive to go out places you
have to drive to go to the bar you have drive to
go to the movies whatever it's very a lonely City
it can be and I think that's a sort of universal
thing that people have experienced loneliness in
a city in the in the wanting to belong to some
extent the other thing that was interestingly
marketable about 1BR is when it came out we came
out during covid it was very meta in the way that
we're sitting here during covert can I trust that
neighbor can I trust that neighbor you don't trust
your neighbors and this movie's coming out it's
only about not trusting your neighbors to some
extent so there was sort of an interesting angle
to that that just happened to be because of covid
but in terms of the marketing of it look
we we worked very hard on the trailer
we worked very hard on the poster we really
put them through the ringer we kept on sending
it back that gives away the whole movie do
this do this cut this do this let's change
the voice at the end of the trailer and
we did to throw people off even more right
the that the we had elements we have a pretty
girl who's in peril and she's going through
this terrible experience these are kind of
things that are very common in the horror
space there's the idea of a final girl the idea
of somebody having to surpass all these obstacles
to to get to this place where they're free is
is very sort of universal in its own right too
but look the main thing was this in terms of
marketing the film we had trailer moments and
we had enough critical claim they were able to
bake that into there too all you see a bunch of
different quotes from critics that are coming
up that are actually really pointed well one
BR could be a new cult classic one broke you
put things in there that and it kind of turns
people's heads it gets them to notice right and
also we don't give away too much in the trailer
which I think is important too people watched me
oh you didn't give anything away so that that's I
hope that answers the question in terms of what's
marketable at the film got a good trailer we had
a barely striking poster in fact the trailer got
nominated for a golden trailer award it was one
of the only independent films in that category
we lost the Joker so I feel not only saying that
we did a good job with the trailer someone
else a major the importance thought so too.
Film Courage: Who came up
with the poster for 1BR Movie?
Alok: It was our distributor had an artist who
initially came up with sort of the idea of him
we had a couple different ideas and then we chose
the best one and then we started nitpicking at it
to do different things to put a palm tree
in there and to put people on the walkway
and make them more menacing or did we went with
them back and forth for a couple months and went
back and forth with them so yeah it was it's
their artist idea but then we helped mold it.
Film Courage: While you were making 1BR how
much are you thinking about the marketing?
Alok: We were trying to look I think that you have
to sort of see what you have first frankly we were
thinking about different ideas of what to do but
we the initial thought for the whole thing was
that we would have a festival run first and that
we would go to a we would hopefully get into a
major Festival one of the two I mentioned before
Citrus or Fantasia that has a Marketplace there
and the idea was to go there and have people
watch two screens of it and we know there was
a lot of Distributors that would be there and we
were hoping a bidding war got started and indeed
it did get started there so that was the plan
to First do a festival run get the awareness
and hopefully get a distributor and then it was we
knew we'd have to work with the distributor they
want to feel they're they know more they would
tell you and maybe they do on certain for certain
aspects for example we never cut a trailer before
we went to Festival because it's time and expense
for you you probably can't do it better than the
guys that are paid to do it I can tell you that
and once it gets into the Google Sphere or
whatever it's hard to pull that back right
that's the first thing people are going to
see from your movie so if you're going to do
something for a festival for awareness maybe pick
a scene from the movie and put that out there yeah
that's probably good enough because invariable
will happen is the distributor is going to want
to put going to want to come up with their trailer
their own trailer in fact because you could maybe
put something great together and be oh thanks
for the time and expense we're not going to use
that we're going to come up with something else
right so that's that's sort of what the what the
plan was for us we didn't have a trailer we got to
the to the festival we got a bidding war started
we sold the movie to we gave gave the rights
to this distributor and then we proceeded to
finish up the festival world tour at the same
time working on the trailer and the poster
with a distributor but you have some bumpy starts
because you didn't have it finished but you sent
it to 17. yes they they basically the the year
the let's say our fall of 2018 when we had just
finished the reshoots we tried to quickly put the
things in that into the the cut we had and then
send that off and so basically from September
of 2018 until I want to say almost May of 2019
we had been rejected all over the place but we
were testing it and actually still cutting it down
and making it Tighter and Tighter and in terms
of helping the testing helped us with that quite
a lot and it actually helped us decide on which
ending we actually shot multiple endings we did
reshoots so it helped us figure out which ending
we were going to go with it helped us figure out
little minute things how much cat violin should
we have in it for example should we have less
should we should more or should we do the answer
was less but all these things helped Titan film
get into shape but finally in in excuse me
may we were accepted by Fantasia and at that
point we were okay now we have our work cut
out for us let's go to these other festivals
and see what we can do and from basically
when we premiered in July of 2019 we were
pretty much going all over the world till
literally January of 2020 right when covid was
starting to hit we finished our last Festival in
in France in the Alps or something and came home
and we're just I'm surprised I don't have covet
so having Fantasia say yes to you is kind of
the popular girl saying yes to go to the dance
and then now you're now you're invited all the
parties 100 it's just that just that she's all
that analogy yeah I took my glasses off and all
of a sudden I did this and all of a sudden yeah
essentially that's what it is it's it's you get
you get validated by a a real taste maker Fantasia
and all of a sudden everyone's wait wait what okay
yeah okay I'll take a look yeah no problem and
people came to us too it wasn't just us having
to go out and you know pound the pavement and
whatever else people started approaching us
and we're oh my gosh I'd love to put you program
you and okay that's great you were on our list
what changes would you make to the marketing
if you had to do it all over again for one VR
or maybe you wouldn't maybe you did everything
look in the context of what we were living
through in terms of covet and stuff I really
wouldn't have changed anything who's to say
that it would have even done as much marketing
for it if there hadn't been coveted because
frankly we probably would have been on to the
next thing we were just oh this is successful
let's take the success of this and try to
roll it into the next project we're making
if anything that probably hurt us who would hurt
us in that regard because all this heat you're
having during covet is including necessarily
remembered over here it is to some extent but
who knows when you're the hot thing it's better
to try to strike get a deal or some some sort and
get some funding for the next one or whatever at
the same time but I don't know that there's two
interesting things going on with this film one you
have somebody who knows about marketing the film
two you have someone with nothing to do during
covet not a lot to do let's say three you have
someone invested money in the movie so anything
we do is a direct it's directly going to get
our money back for us let's say right so there
is a real reason to try to work at it every day
right so this is an interesting sort of thing that
happened because of the situation we were in covid
going to question would I do anything different
in terms of marketing I don't know that I would I
feel if anything people should do more of what we
did to try to do their films if they they really
think that they have here's the thing if you
don't have something we tested the film right
remember I talked to the scores excellent very
good good Fair poor right we'd score very good
we'd also score for the deathly recommend score it
was very high so we two things happened because of
that one you have a very good move you don't have
an excellent movie because you couldn't afford it
to be at excellent but you have a very good movie
so you can have less fear in terms of pushing that
movie towards journalists towards other people
there's a definitely recommend score that's very
high so again less fear in terms of pushing it
towards journalism journalists and and trying
to get reviews and whatever else invariably people
do the film mostly people the film so again if you
have all those components then maybe it may and
people haven't seen this for a little while kind
of too as well then maybe it makes sense to keep
on pushing this thing right and trying to keep
this not only pushing it because it's original but
and it scores very well but pushing it because you
also want a franchise right these are the all
the reasons that you keep on trying to push it
and trying to do this the marketing for it right
so I guess the answer question I don't think I'd
change the thing if anything I wish I could have
done more if anything I wish I could have had a
publicist assist in most of the major countries we
opened up in but what happens invariably is that
you your distributor sells a sub distributor and
it's up to them to do whatever they're going to do
right for the next one or the future it's what's
becoming very interesting it's becoming such a
digital world so there are companies film Hub and
Indie rights and they have reach that is that is
global now so maybe we open up on iTunes through
our 20 from our company that's only going to take
20 from us it's not going to give it to a sub
distributor we open up ourselves and we open up
all over iTunes all over the world all over Google
play All Over YouTube all over the world next time
and we don't have to take this person that's going
to take their 20 of 20 of whatever and we hire
publicist for the major markets ourselves and we
do it we raise awareness that way that would have
been a if I could have my if I had the money
and I had the wherewithal that's what I would
have done and I can tell you this probably gonna
do next time and sometimes a personal email from
a filmmaker can work just as well I don't know
maybe there is a perception there's a stigma if
you don't have a publicist but sometimes some of
that just goes into this noise category sometimes
but I tell you this though look it's about hiring
the right publicist because there are certain
publicists that are very lazy they're I tried your
movie doesn't start anybody I can't do anything
well why don't you pick up the phone and do your
job that's my question what I know you can call
you if you have a good movie called look I know
you watch a lot of shitty movies I know I've sent
you shitty movies this is a good movie okay please
just watch this please just watch this I promise
you it's good that's what you can do right that's
essentially what we did when we did when we went
and got got reviews and stuff that any publicist
workers Hall can do that too right and it's about
finding the right one who gets your movie who
believes in it who's not gonna just I don't know
what to do with it no go figure something else go
do your job right that's that you need to find the
right partner and that's about doing research
look you do research if I gotta find the best
horror publicist in Germany I don't know who that
person is but I'm gonna find out so you do that
that's what I wish if you could have done that I
would have done that but I'll do that for the next
one because I'm gonna hopefully the money stays
with us more than going to other people next time
because of this digital Marketplace we live in now
and where did you exactly get these test numbers
from aside from going to festivals and seeing what
we tested the movie ourselves we did we didn't it
wasn't as is as formal as what we would do at the
Nielsen RG and different companies I've worked for
otx research we took 20 people at a time watched
had them watch the movie and then did a focus
group on them and we gave them cards and then
we did we did five groups in total so we had
a hundred cards right so we called the data
and we're able to see little you can't see a
lot because it's only 100 people but you can see
patterns and you can see Trends so we were able
to take that information and have the confidence
that that we did have to to do everything we did
where did you find these 20 people these friends
of friends friends of friends friends of friends
some of them maybe a couple of friends and family
but really try to get friends and friends and and
whatever you think whoever you think the
audience is going to play whoever the age
group you're thinking in your mind that's what
you try to get try to get a spread someone knows
somebody and get you a 50 year old or whatever
I do somebody knows I'm gonna get you a teenager
you have to it's it's as much as doing a job
to organize that screening as it is anything
else and people get paid a lot of money to do
that professionally so that's that's the whole
thing if you do it yourself you're doing the poor
man's version of it then then try to ask for help
from friends of friends everyone has social media
you can go on Facebook and be hey friends I need
some help we're testing this movie getting some
friends of friends I'm gonna feed you dinner we
might give you a glass of wine I'm not exactly
scientific I know but just enough to they they
feel appreciated and they're gonna hopefully see
something interesting ah so this was they saw it
as a group and they saw it in person it wasn't a
screener yeah interesting we wanted to get them
in a room and then do a focus group on them so
I know a lot of moderators in the business so
we were able to get moderators for each of those
five groups and that gives us more information too
we would tape those conversations and and doing a
moderator gets you different information than you
would get on the page as well there's something
organic about it a lot of times and people feel
free hopefully if it's a good moderator and
they feel able to talk about their feelings
and they don't feel they have to mix the words or
whatever right and so then did you get a special
screening haul or this was just at someone's
home just just on my house oh okay great.